welcome to you get cooking in cloud
where we share the best recipes to apply
in your cloud kitchen I'm Priyanka and
in this episode we welcome back jet
person to talk about more mobile app
back in service solutions
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning Jen welcome to get cooking
into out thanks Priyanka always happy to
be here so last time we were on the show
you shared a mobile app back-end recipe
solution using firebase yep and I
explained that firebase solves a lot of
the mobile app back-end problems but if
you need to make some changes
server-side I hinted that you need to
add to firebase to make a complete
solution so I can't wait any longer tell
me what we're cooking up today all right
so here is our recipe from the last
episode and here's today's ingredients
of course App Engine standard
environment while App Engine standard
environment is an app platform that
monitors updates and skills the hosting
environment all you need to do is write
your mobile backend service code if your
app uses firebase for automatic
real-time data synchronization you can
extend your firebase solution using App
Engine standard environment to process
user data or orchestrate events for
instance in my game Priyanka's kitchen I
use App Engine to compute user ranks
based on scores then write the updated
ranks to firebase that's a perfect
example of how this recipe can be used
I recommend this recipe for firebase
apps that need a back-end service to
modify the synchronize data and back-end
services that run periodically to
process or analyze firebase data just
like the ranking system in Priyanka's
kitchen App Engine standard environment
suddenly adds some seasoning to the
firebase recipe but of course no one
recipe will suit every discerning palate
so tell me Jen when would you not
recommend using certain I don't
recommend you use today's recipe for
back-end services that call native
binaries right to the file system or
make other system calls I also don't
recommend this if you require persistent
connections to firebase because App
Engine standard environment reclaim
socket connections after just two
minutes but I'm betting that you have a
design that can work for those use cases
too right yeah I have it right here
but you'll have to wait to the next
episode to find out what it is oh I am
on the edge of my seat here
thanks again for coming on and it's
always a pleasure to spend time on cloud
kitchen with you anytime I can't wait to
come back to your kitchen I just love
the smell of freshly cooked cloud well
that's all for today on get cooking in
cloud if you would like to know more
about today's recipe you can check out
the resources in the description below
here's hoping you're whipping up your
own mobile app back-end strategy join us
next time when Jen will finally reveal
the mystery mobile app back in solution
if you like this video then check out
the other episodes in the series and
don't forget to subscribe to our YouTube
channel so you can be notified about new
episodes of get cooking and cloud as
well as other great google cloud content
[Music]